again i mentioned offhandedly to chris
so like i i guess i'll go through the
timeline this is interesting i don't
know if it is not whatever i mentioned
to chris was like let's do this i want
to do this why the [ __ ] not yeah and i
thought like chris would say no because
you know when you have a crazy idea and
you're like
it's crazy if i say it to someone and
they say no immediately yeah because
then you're like okay i guess it is
crazy but if you say a crazy idea to
someone they're like
okay
you're like oh
maybe it's not that insane right maybe
we can like do this yeah and so i was
like you get a video i'll live stream
the whole thing
i didn't know and then he was like yeah
sure let's do it and then i was like
wait [ __ ] what if is there signaling
like whack an eye cause i remember when
we drove yeah there was no signal in
some parts no i was like wait [ __ ] can i
actually do this wait how do i keep
everything cool wait how do i run it for
10 hours in a backpack i need to buy a
bike how do i charge my phone like how
do i read chat
i also want to do this thing it was just
like
i agreed to do it and then there's a
billion things i had to figure out yeah
and it was just oh my god it was awful
awful i didn't know how to buy anything
i didn't know what to buy
who just i don't know anyone who cycles
in japan yeah so i just started asking
around these great guys who've been
helping me with a lot of irl streaming
stuff i just kind of messaged and i was
like hey how do i um
how do i how do i check if i can stream
in this place
and they were like oh just go check out
like cell towers so i'm like yeah sick i
open up a map of cell towers that's like
none right it's like for like three days
there's like no cell phone towers
they're like all right but maybe maybe
if you like go along this really
specific road and stay on this road you
can do it but you need to go to docomo
and get like docomo sims yeah so docomo
is like the old
government cell phone company so a lot
of the rural areas in japan uh are
mainly like docomo yeah i was like [ __ ]
okay right so now i gotta go and get two
more phone contracts and buy two new
modems and figure out how that's gonna
happen and then i was like wait my my
bag is like [ __ ] for cycling so i asked
like rob rob dc great streamer he helped
me out came to my house told me what to
buy
dude rob is a go so i actually got the
idea from rob yeah because he did a
cycling thing as well yeah again this is
going even more back rob did a stream
where he cycled across japan for like 30
days i think it was from tokyo to kyushu
somewhere and like back and back yeah
he's he's he's actually a madman yeah
yeah yeah
you know uh because it's a cyclothon
subathons every time you saw the sub the
thing went higher yeah yeah and i was
like i don't do that yeah i just want to
like i just want to like do this
give me a beginning and end point yeah
yeah yeah so that's that's what we did
and you know
credit to him really nice guy helped me
out with it a bunch because you know a
lot of people are like hey i kind of
want to did what you did can you give me
advice and help me out a lot of people
be like no no that's my idea don't steal
that
and so he was like he's you know
super helpful we did even helped me do
like a test stream
we tested the bag out it did not work
properly it was like overheating right
the next day he was like dude don't
worry i got you i'll come over we'll
install a fan in your bag yeah so we we
installed a pc fan in my bag
to cool my bag so you're basically
carrying a towel i'm literally carrying
like you've got a pc tower yeah
like i'm carrying like and again another
another problem it's like i have this
like it's just every time i would do
something that's how stressful it was
just another problem would come up yeah
okay so i have this bag with four modems
uh live broadcasting tool and now it's
got a pc fan how the [ __ ] do i power all
this i had a really big battery turns
out a really big battery can't go on the
plane to go to wakanda so then i have to
call up the hotel i'm like hey can i
ship some stuff to your hotel right and
they were like yeah all good so that was
okay problem i'm avoided yeah how do you
buy a new battery like a 300 battery 50
000 milliamp battery it's like it's
literally the one thing it's the [ __ ]
uh camping one right right right like
it's the thing
five kilograms yeah and it's like [ __ ]
this is on my back
and it's like all right okay so so we
have all these problems so i had to lay
everything out in the bag like with
velcro so it's all evenly distributed so
that i'm it's not just weighing me down
and killing my back yeah yeah yeah
perfect done so then i'm like all right
now i need a bike
i'm telling you man one of the hardest
things on earth is trying to figure out
a good bike yeah online it is like when
you look online it's like what is good
bike and it's literally like i bought
this tour de france bike for fifteen
thousand dollars it's pretty good but if
you're a more budget option we've got a
9k bike here for amateurs and it's like
what the [ __ ] is any of this like
literally every time i try and buy a new
camera yeah it's like cyclists are so
like insular with their like suggestions
and stuff yeah yeah yeah you know these
sunglasses they kind of deflected the
micro wind uh you know in like a 0.3 you
know and then the uv with the zero point
three speaking english it was just like
i just didn't understand anything yeah
about cycling yeah and there's a guy
called josh in japan who was really
great and he helped me out and he
basically he cycles a ton in japan he
just gave me all the suggestions told me
to what pence to bought i bought new
cycling pants that had like uh straps
straps that went over there they were
awesome they were great i like didn't
chafe at all it was great they stayed up
all the pain was a pain in the ass
because i have to tip my shirt off every
time i want to pee
again it was so expensive because i
bought like a pretty good bike right
yeah yeah i bought a bike it was called
cannondale synapse 3l it's like a 4 000
bike all right yeah i was like
government if you're listening i'm never
riding it ever outside of this one
charity event um so it's a tax write-off
please please but yeah so it was just
like a month of crazy prep and getting
everything ready yeah yeah just hoping
like how do you test this like i can't
go to wakanae in the middle of nowhere
in hokkaido and test if this works yeah
exactly so like i'm [ __ ] myself yeah
and i'm in i'm in like in basically like
sudo russia in japan you're in the
middle of nowhere and like just day one
you're like you turn everything on and
you just hope it works and yeah some
things broke right away and you're like
[ __ ] like our tires we didn't like
inflate them properly and then
um stuff wasn't working and i had to um
so another thing is that it was for
charity yeah and i wanted there to be
text to speech on my speaker for all the
donations coming through because i
thought that would be fun yeah i can
incentivize people and also i'm gonna be
cycling like all day like nine hours
don't have something to keep your mind
occupied yeah my mind like numb yeah and
um so like turns out that
uh the charity service i was using
tiltify
just doesn't let you do text-to-speech
in any way really there's no way you can
do text-to-speech with it uh through
like stream labs yeah yeah yeah um
stream elements anything it doesn't work
and uh so shout out to stream elements
and my uh one of my mods i just asked
someone like hey could you make
something you should program something
that will read text-to-speech so both of
them made things so stream elements just
made a a plug-in just for this charity
event wow so that i could have charity
donations come out on the speaker right
in like three days shout out to them
jesus do so many people helped like yeah
like my mod who's just uh rode who's
awesome who manages our subreddit as
well he made like a live tracking thing
yeah i saw that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i i can't really use this in day
like normal stream because i don't want
everyone to know
[Music]
yourself it's literally like doxing
where i am like yeah yeah in real time
yeah right um make sure you don't
accidentally show that next year
but it's sick though right because it's
like i thought like okay
again like another issue is like how
how do you make nine hours of cycling
engaging yeah because like that shit's
boring like i i wouldn't watch it yeah
but it's like okay so you have you have
the narrative of the the charity and the
challenge right and and the journey
that's one but that's that's not really
like like you if you missed day one you
maybe you don't care about that as much
yeah it's like so i was like okay i
really want to have some kind of like
progress bar or tracker on the screen
yeah uh and i just you know three weeks
before the event i asked my mods i was
like hey can you can we try and make
something and yeah they made it it took
it was like pulling hair testing this
app it was like every night they're like
we tested again and i just sat there for
an hour and they were like type this on
android editor and i was like dude it's
broken it doesn't work
and hours hours yeah it took me so long
but then you get this cool result where
you get this progress bar that tells you
how far i am from the destination a
little monkey on the map a little
animation that was a custom app that was
made yeah yeah it was a custom app
called find my monkey that they made
wow um it was like literally like every
morning before the cycle i would zoom in
on where i was put start zoom out go to
where we're gonna finish put end yeah
and it would just do like a geographical
straight line yeah which wasn't like
perfect because sunday's people be like
wow what an easy day we have 60 but then
the root was like this yeah yeah yeah so
it was actually like 120 and we're like
wow he's moving so slowly but luckily we
had like a speedometer as well right
which was using gps to show how fast i
was going which is also fun because then
chat was like oh my god he's moving at
like 50 kilometers an hour on this
downhill everyone's getting hyped yeah
it was just like
trying to like gamify it and trying to
make it like engaging i think that it
worked yeah people already liked it and
like views were crazy for me yeah
exactly i saw you peek to like 30 000 at
the end yeah
41 or something like that i've never had
that many viewers ever on a live stream
yeah yeah and that's nice that's [ __ ]
insane yeah it was it was crazy it was
uh it's hard though because cycling with
the backpack on it was like it was a lot
and then also trying to like be fun
cycling is hard yeah yeah yeah for sure
um that was hot that was hardest part i
felt like some days i wasn't engaging
enough at that point i think there's
enough elements within the stream that
you didn't need to be engaged yeah no
one's gonna blame you for that yeah yeah
dude i think for the first like four or
five days i was killing it with the
engagement i thought i was like just
talking non-stop even though cycling
yeah um except for like uphills i was
like all right chad just
but even that was fun because like i i
think i think it all worked really
nicely where we had enough elements in
it um where everyone kind of came
together and when like uphill sections
happened that were really long everyone
was just kind of like in cheering mode
and that was really fun
it was just everything worked like i was
very lucky that
we never had a signal outage more than
like 20 30 minutes right and even then
most of them were like one minute right
right yeah yeah yeah so yeah it worked i
i don't know i think it's a [ __ ]
miracle that all worked out yeah i don't
know the battery lasted every single day
i i
my i had a 50 000 milliamp battery and
it only
died on the very very last day after 10
hours of streaming damn with four things
plugged into it god damn okay and then
it would last like another hour on like
residual charges right right so that's
like crazy yeah i'm i i'm yeah it was
nuts i didn't even talk about how like
how the cycling actually was just the
prep and doing it was hard yeah that was
hard yeah cause like like i saw how many
things you had going on in like irl
stream setup and everything like that
and i was just like is this custom-made
or is this like although it was like
custom yeah yeah